we make this mistake all the time in our
relationships which is we think we have
to be honest in the moment but we don't
read the room and understand that
there's too much emotion involved to
have a rational conversation you know
somebody's mad at us and we're going
this is not the time for rational
feedback you meet emotion with emotion
you meet rational with rational you
can't mix the two and sometimes we're
rational but they're emotional which
means we have to stand down right so
what I've learned about honesty is we
have to be honest but we can actually
delay you have to meet rational with and
emotional with emotional